Thank you.
And thank you for having me in this beautiful office.
It's super cool.
So Synth is essentially a probabilistic intelligence layer for asset prices.
So we focus very much on getting people to forecast price path distributions versus trying to forecast just individual prices in the future.
Which is.
Is pretty common for most kind of finance competitions trading competitions a lot of them are focused on
like point predictions some point in the future
and we're focused on distributions
so you know you've really got to try
and forecast where the price will go
and how it will go there
so the competition is based on Bittensor as a subnet.
Competitors.
Submit a thousand paths or Monte Carlo simulations.
Every hour on a continuous basis and are scored on.
How accurate their distributions are to the actual price.
So it's live, it's ongoing.
And yeah.
Super excited to, you know.
Expand.
The different people that can access the competition by working with Crunch.
We've spent a lot of time being my co-founder Sam,
like building out different trading systems.
Especially in crypto decentralized finance.
We've also competed in competitions in the past
like Numerai competition.
And we really like the idea that, you know, you can get you can crowdsource intelligence.
And for us there.
You know, around a year ago.
We started to think about what would agents
and LLMs that are going to be
like the primary users of markets in the future, what do they need?
And they already have access to
like all the historical data they could want.
And they're very good at answering questions about historical data.
But LLMs agents aren't very good at answering questions about the future
so can you create this intelligence layer that they can tap into to answer questions better about the future
and for this you want to have get an open competition
or you want to have a lot of competitors who can kind of create a really robust data layer intelligence layer that people can tap into
and um.
For that you need to have a very transparent scoring mechanism you need to make sure it's fair
and you need to make sure the participants are well paid
and we think we've achieved a lot of those things with synth
and we now have a very competitive environment.
With high reward
like roughly around a hundred thousand dollars per month in rewards going out to participants which is cool
and we have really strong data sets that agents can tap into
but we've also seen like.
Trading firms.
Different traders.
People who do risk management also tapping into this data.
and you can apply it to
like options markets prediction markets
and it's cool.
so we use continuous rank probability scoring system.
So you're continuously ranked on how close your distributions are to the actual price movement.
And this rewards people who are confident
and like very confident in their distribution
and are correct.
It punishes people who are confident and incorrect.
And people who are vague,
the more vague you are,
the more likely you are to have a very mediocre score.
And the subnet is weighted to people who have,
you know, accurate predictions.
Accurate forecasts of distributions.
They receive the most rewards.
So yeah.
It's quite hard to cheat.
There's also like a negative cost.
So if you try and do things
like register lots of participants.
Then.
it's very unlikely that will be successful some will get deregistered
and there's a cost to that
so we found that
like the scoring mechanism has kind of evolved over time it's got a lot more robust
and yet it's in a in a great position
right now so people should
you know we call it
like a proper scoring rule
like the best you know the optimal strategy is to try
and really um.
Try and be as accurate as possible from the very beginning
and just improve your model over time.
And it's very likely you're going to do well.
Exactly.
I think that's what we love about working with Crunch is that.
It's making the subnet more expect more accessible making the competition much more accessible
and we're discussing as well earlier
like there's so many more tools available now
and you don't have to be an expert in finance by any means to enter the competition
right especially through crunch you can.
You know just have skills from different industries
and this is a great place to learn about time series Monte Carlo simulations
and modeling so it's very exciting.
absolutely.
So firstly.
Like it is very competitive, like
because the prices are significant.
That's roughly like 80 to $100,000 per month in rewards going out to participants.
So yeah.
The prizes are significant.
So yeah, there is a lot of competition.
Real players are coming in. And yeah.
Some of them have also worked at, you know.
Various places where they've got some experience with this but.
the quality of the data over the last few months has improved
like a lot we ran an experiment on polymarket where we're trading some binary up down yes/no up/down markets
and we had an account i think it started around 3000 turned into 60 to 70 000
and i mean recently
like that was cool.
Recently we've seen some interesting behavior on the market.
On Polymarket.
So we created a dashboard, we created some tools
so people can...
use or they can
you know see if there's any discrepancies between Synth's probabilistic forecasts
and the Polymarket prices on certain markets which can help them with their own trading
so we're also very excited about yeah.
we saw last week around a week ago.
someone was moving the price of BTC to try
and win markets they also moving the price of XRP
you know just like 10 20 seconds before the end of the market
and we were seeing a lot of discrepancy in you know.
This potentially caused a lot of
like automated systems that didn't have
like this level of data to lose money
so we think that
like probabilistic forecasts that they can be useful for a huge amount of kind of things across trading across risk management you can
you know integrate this data into
like automated trading systems options market
so yeah.
There's a lot of applications.
But as you said.
The key is to have a great competition
so really great strong robust data comes out of it.
I think like we've seen
like we've seen a lot of demand for crypto data.
But we've added equities
and we think that there's going to be a huge amount of demand for
like 24-7 data across equities as we see
like stock exchanges that they're all moving to become 24-5.
Exactly. Yeah.
So 24 hour trading is coming.
No sleep in 2026.
we didn't have in.
2025.
too long.
Exactly.
So like, there's gonna be this big regime shift.
Right where equities come onchain.
I think probabilistic data is going to become a lot more important.
And we're seeing a lot of demand for this people.
using the data within
like risk management systems within trading systems.
I also think that the way that we have like this new.
Kind of group of pro retail traders emerging
so people who have started using different tools
like different technologies to start trading
so maybe it's you know building their own algorithms
or maybe they're using Claude to create
like more complex trading strategies than they used to have maybe they're integrating different data sets into their trading strategies I think this trend is going to continue over the coming year.
and so there'll be more demand for probabilistic data for sure i think it's creating
like this perfect storm
so we're in a good position
but no sleep in 2026.
It sounds.
Good question.
In total, we have nine assets.
So we may add more in the future.
Like we may also
like we like our goal is to create this
like this kind of broad intelligence layer
right so we definitely will add some more assets kind of based on demand we're seeing
like silver is in demand
right now it's had great performance recently
so potentially adding in silver models in the future we might add in more equities we're pretty open.
to kind of responding to demand
but right now we've just added in some equity
so we'll make sure that performance is good there
and then we'll see in the near future.
Yes so i think like the key thing is to really think about
like this is a volatility modeling competition um.
Volatility is based on multiple factors.
But right now.
Volatility is very much based on different news events
so reacting to those news events
or having ways to bring that data into your model is very important.
Exactly so news is moving the market significantly
so I think it's key to
like try and bring in different news feeds social media data into your models that can really help performance.
So Pyth is the price data
and the oracle we use it's very robust they're they have a great system
but for your modeling like.
You know, you can explore different data sets.
Right? As many different data sets as possible.
And yeah.
You mentioned that's also now possible.
Solana.
So.
Amazing.
That's, yeah.
Awesome.
Let's do it.
Super excited.
Thank you so much.